sci-fi movies and books depict a future
with sentinel machines capable of
interacting with humans and performing
tasks just like people would
what if we told you that this future is
already a reality
all of this is already made possible by
machine learning
machine learning is the science of
programming machines to think and act
like humans without being specifically
programmed to
we already use machine learning in our
daily life without knowing it
email spam recognition spell check even
the youtube video recommendation which
brought you here are implemented using
machine
learning machine learning uses
algorithms to learn tasks
these algorithms are fed with data from
which they learn to perform these tasks
this means that over time as changes in
data occur
we don't need to reprogram our
application just let it find
patterns and learn from the new data
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence
which is a science concerned with
imparting human-like intelligence onto
machines and creating machines which can
sense
reason act and adapt deep learning is a
sub-branch of machine learning which is
inspired by the working of the human
brain
machine learning is leading us to a
future where machines can learn and
think
and has opened us a whole new plethora
of job opportunities
this was a brief intro to machine
learning if you like this video
do give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the simply learn channel for more
content like this
don't forget to hit the bell icon to
receive notifications
what do you think machine learning will
be capable of in the near future
let us know in the comments till then
stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here